so if you look at that one that one look
like I kind of got hit did she write or
look good yes hey guys I'm I'm Bernstein
and this is my brother Ryder how you
doing and today we're going to talk to
you about stuff more slow the street
didn't definitely we have like give a
really good fix going but your primary
is acting and my primary thing is not so
sure you've knows like the ins and outs
of the Safeway I just like throw myself
more things hoping I don't break my leg
there's a saying that that my friend
really like to say really is the man
with the sword and shadow of Mordor and
as he says the difference between a man
and a daredevil the something has to go
to work the next day basically what that
means that stunt is all about safety
you're gonna you're going to leave you
the wind knocked out here sure okay
underneath a lot of your stuff is
there's a lot of padding a lot of
trickery like a lot of old Hong Kong
reading some like that but not people
like to take fall like the hit like nice
little just like that credible they
actually have special tables made where
it's like this the sides are actually
foam so windy you want to go for the
roof it's like surprisingly loud
[Applause]
wait town is ready we're stirring many
things other treaters of in school get a
running start just go right into that
tree nice I don't hate that I do that
stuff don't need to worry all right a
useless thing how do I go stunts the
name the game is longevity which means
you have to take care of your body you
have to know what you're doing people
think it's like alright hey I'm not for
you take a hit I'm not afraid to fall
that means I can do stunts right but
it's like that's not the same things
like this is when you hit a barrel you
went onto your back oh that was a great
recall because with balls it's a lot
more beneficial to take it onto your
back as long as you land in certain ways
because you're diverting a lot of that
horse use it to rotate and you're
controlling sit down to the ground
because you are doing dangerous stuff we
have to do it as safely as possible so
three main things that I would take in
consideration when approaching a stunt
is a what is the stuff that I'm actually
trying to show and so in this case we'll
use a chokeslam which is this precise
the
be what can I do to make this as safe as
possible and so in that case we'll be
patting up or flying in Pass
[Music]
and then see how can I best capture this
that way I don't have to do multiple
takes of this and also sells the effect
if you want some like really hit they
have to throw a big reactions reactions
which is like the person getting hit or
whatever that is arguably even more
important than the person actions
telling the strike that one that one
looked like I kind of got kids
since you're right see that the look is
good right it's like they're you just
just kind of like clobbered me a bit I
throw it right here it still looks like
a hit right all right you know we're
going to do that again I mean here so I
have punched right there if I got some
point real contact it's like I'm strong
it's very trained able to stop right
here most people are going to do that
we're actually fighting I'm probably not
going to be able to actually stop it
Kyle you're definitely the hit me right
in the face oh yeah right there
she's got a broken nose bloody you've
got to go to hospital your entire sheet
is cancelled because you didn't
understand camera angles as a
combination of safety it's a
collaboration between stunt people
directors and cinematographers wait did
he really lock us in yes working closes
hat and then in both watch we do want a
ladder it was like a hundred percent ten
he did so true actually here's a fun
little tip and stuff like that not that
you should do stair Falls but the actual
thing that's their fault that you're
supposed to do is you try to hit a view
of stairs as possible falling and then
launching itself over multiple stairs
that way there's less impact constantly
going soon there's certain home run
dressed
hey Siri call Carmichael
no don't call Alicia you wanted to wring
climbing down this Bush rend
now there's spiders in there there's a
there's literally a pile of rusty metal
you're not in the end I'm not going to
do that no we're telega toby back there
for buddy in our video in bern
screenwriter you and written both look
like to hike fall off of the technical
side
well it's good also you guys are sorting
a lot and your legs which could result
in like blowouts and stuff like that how
do you do that i call actually did do it
in this video i don't know if it was a
combination of footage but basically
when you do jump you want to do a
shoulder roll which is all spoon and of
course when you hit you go forward and
roll over that shoulder from shoulder to
the opposite hip but you never actually
want to go and put your hands to
straight down to the puppet shot going
it will break your wrist break your arm
so you want to know how she rolled out
but they're free on the roof
how you feeling a little bit
we hit down on sunburn you guys on other
hand I don't know
this is off sale hey John John John we
have a predicament here flip man for
said look what you done enough for the
save perfect you're not resting we're
gonna make it already thinking of you
know B yeah you know I you know if you
want to watch more fight stuff that we
put out Carmichael and Nico put out a
video a couple years ago talking about
fights and why fight scenes suck if you
watch it continue watching listen all
the play go home it's very very
difficult to film these kind of scenes
and that's actually why you don't see
them very often in fact what many
filmmakers tend to do to save money if
they imply the action rather than
showing it